Traduttore: Roberto Minelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Parliamo della paura del diverso,
e di sue possibili origini.
Circa un secolo fa,
Freud diventò una delle persone
più influenti del mondo
dicendo, in sostanza
una cosa abbastanza semplice:
noi esseri umani siamo una specie animale,
per quanto molto complessa,
frutto di un'evoluzione.
Quindi abbiamo un corpo, degli istinti.
Se questi istinti,
che devono essere espressi
in forme civili,
vengono troppo compressi
si hanno poi le nevrosi
e i disturbi mentali.
Chiediamoci se non ci sono -
naturalmente, la sessualità,
oggi, dopo un secolo,
ha trovato infinite espressioni
più libere per esprimersi -
ma chiediamoci
se non ci sono altri istinti
che, invece, non hanno ricevuto
questo allargamento del loro campo
o, addirittura, il cui campo
di espressione si è ristretto.
Se, per esempio, abbiamo un cane
notiamo che anche se vive
in un appartamento cittadino
ha conservato un istinto del territorio.
Che ne è dell'istinto del territorio
della specie Homo sapiens?
Nella nostra evoluzione
eravamo già Homo Sapiens
quando siamo passati da nomadi a stanziali
con l’invenzione dell'agricoltura.
Ma, anche nel corso della storia,
fino all'inizio del ‘900,
gli storici ci dicono
che l'individuo normale medio -
persino in Europa,
la stragrande maggioranza -
conosceva 200 persone nella propria vita.
Questo non poneva
grandi problemi di spazio
né di diffidenza che, naturalmente,
si mette in moto -
è un altro istinto necessario,
non possiamo fidarci di tutti -
quando qualcuno entra nel nostro spazio.
Tra l'altro, abbiamo visto, da allora,
la popolazione - dall'inizio ‘900 -
si è moltiplicata per quasi otto volte.
Nel secolo scorso, nell'ultimo secolo,
c'è stata un’urbanizzazione travolgente.
E dieci anni fa, le Nazioni
Unite hanno comunicato
che la popolazione del mondo
è a maggioranza urbana
e la sproporzione continua ad aumentare
perché masse immense continuano
a trasferirsi nelle città,
perché offrono più opportunità.
Anche se offrono -
per esempio, i disturbi mentali
sono infinitamente più alti
nella vita cittadina.
Cosa succede nelle città?
Noi incontriamo non centinaia,
ma migliaia di persone, se usciamo.
Non nella nostra vita, ma ogni giorno.
E, se qualcuno va al lavoro
con i mezzi pubblici,
per esempio la metropolitana,
siamo costretti a stare così
con un altro centinaio di persone -
una cosa piuttosto innaturale,
per il nostro istinto del territorio.
Notiamo, tra l'altro, che quei famosi 200
corrispondono, quasi esattamente,
a ciò che le modernissime neuroscienze
ci dicono [essere] una funzione
principale del nostro cervello.
Il nostro cervello è fatto
per immagazzinare fino a 150 volti,
arrivando ai 200 comincia
a entrare in confusione,
di più non li riconosce.
Questo significa - dicono,
per esempio, i neuroscienziati -
che i social stanno ingannando
radicalmente le nuove generazioni
perché gli dicono:
“Avrete migliaia di amici”
Il che, dicono,
è assolutamente impossibile,
a meno di non falsare
e svuotare completamente
un concetto importante
come quello di amicizia.
Comunque, noi siamo compressi,
per esempio nei vagoni,
e i nostri istinti sono violentati,
[ma] la nostra buona educazione
ci impedisce scopi di aggressività.
Ma sarebbe impossibile imporre,
anche agli animali più intelligenti
e più vicini a noi, come gli scimpanzé,
di rinchiudersi in 100 in un vagone.
Tutto questo è notevolmente aggravato -
questo senso di disagio, di diffidenza -
negli ultimi tempi,
dal fatto che molte delle persone
con cui condividiamo lo spazio
sono improvvisamente,
doppiamente, sconosciuti.
Cioè, sono immigrati.
Il nostro era un paese di emigrazione,
non esistevano, no?
Sono diversi per colore
della pelle, per lingua.
E, purtroppo, anche qui,
gli studiosi degli istinti ci dicono,
a un certo punto,
questa sovrapposizione
tra natura e cultura,
gli istinti vengono ingannati
e non li riconoscono più
come appartenenti alla specie umana.
Scatta l'aggressività
che noi abbiamo verso le altre specie.
Facciamo un passaggio:
dagli istinti dell'individuo
ai grandi movimenti della Storia.
Sappiamo che, nel secolo scorso,
Hitler provocò una delle
maggiori catastrofi che si ricordino
perché propose, come
spiegazione semplicissima -
di nuovo quasi animalesca, istintiva -
alla Germania in uno stato
di ansia senza precedenti
a causa della sconfitta
della Prima Guerra Mondiale
e, successivamente, della
grande inflazione senza precedenti
per cui non si sapeva
come si sarebbe vissuti all'indomani,
la spiegazione che il paese
stava degenerando
perché perdeva la sua
purezza razziale necessaria.
Oggi sappiamo che il concetto
di razza che si usava
è antiscientifico.
E accusava gli ebrei di complotto.
Non tentò neanche mai di dimostrare
l’esistenza di questi complotti:
passò direttamente alle leggi razziali,
costruzioni di campi di concentramento,
poi di sterminio e poi guerra.
Questa intolleranza,
anche delle diversità minime,
è nota alla psicopatologia come paranoia.
Il paranoico è una persona
così incapace di psicologia
che non riesce a riconoscere
nessun errore dentro di sé
e, quindi, segue dei meccanismi istintivi
per cui, visto che l'errore esiste,
deve sempre puntare il dito
contro un autore dell’errore esterno.
Notiamo che, a differenza
di altre forme di patologia mentale -
la schizofrenia, la depressione -
che escludono della società,
la paranoia ha questa
particolarità pericolosissima:
che in mano a persone
dotate di potere politico
funge addirittura, invece,
non da esclusione ma
da moltiplicatore del loro potere
in momenti di ansietà
collettiva particolare.
E l'antropologia, qui,
ci dà un suggerimento:
e cioè che in tutte le società -
di nuovo, a livello
molto semplice di reazioni,
cioè nelle società tribali
a uno stadio primario -
esistono dei riti
di questo tipo, purificatori:
il rito del capro espiatorio.
Cioè, moltissime società tribali
che vivono - che so io -
semplicemente di caccia,
se un anno c'è poca selvaggina
non si chiedono, come noi,
qual è il motivo razionale
per questa assenza.
No, cercano una spiegazione magica:
si chiedono chi ha gettato il malocchio,
identificano il portatore del malocchio,
lo sacrificano
e - antropologia e psicanalisi ci dicono -
effettivamente ottengono,
per un tempo limitato, un sollievo.
Funziona come psicoterapia collettiva.
Non molto diversamente
da come Hitler o Stalin,
in scala molto più immensa,
additando il nemico razziale o di classe
ottenevano un certo consenso
proprio nella popolazione traumatizzata
dalle loro stesse politiche repressive.
A questo punto passiamo ai nostri tempi,
e chiediamoci se abbiamo
sempre bisogno di spiegazioni razionali
o, con tutti gli strumenti culturali
di cui disponiamo,
non potremmo diventare
effettivamente più ragionevoli.
In realtà, il progresso
tecnico-scientifico
non è necessariamente seguito
da un progresso morale.
Sono 500 anni che abbiamo la stampa,
eppure continuiamo
ad accorgerci del fatto
che i mass media - che ci mettono
sempre più informazioni a disposizione -
alle volte ci offrono più verità,
alle volte invece moltiplicano
non la verità ma la falsità.
Con la fine del secolo scorso
è entrato in gioco anche Internet -
altro passo immenso
nel progresso tecnico -
e, tuttavia, già dall'inizio,
è stato studiato il cosiddetto
“paradosso di Internet”
e cioè: se io voglio diventare
più competente in qualcosa,
Internet mi dà informazioni crescenti,
quindi il mio sapere cresce.
Ma di nuovo - siamo umani -
fino a un certo limite:
se voglio farlo crescere all'infinito,
cresce la mia confusione,
dopo una certa soglia,
invece della vera competenza.
E, negli ultimissimi anni,
a questo si è aggiunto
anche l'uso dei social.
I quali, di nuovo,
ci danno il grande vantaggio
di arrivare a moltissime persone,
in tutte le direzioni.
E, tuttavia, gli studi sui social
ci dicono che tendono tutti a privilegiare
messaggi particolarmente brevi.
I messaggi brevi sono, purtroppo,
non quelli che contengono
degli studi e delle spiegazioni accurate
ma le semplificazioni
aggressive e accusatorie.
Cioè, di nuovo, un puntare il dito
e cercare il capro espiatorio.
Tanto è vero che, probabilmente, saprete
che ci sono stati dei morti,
a causa di questo.
In certi paesi sono state
postate su Facebook
informazioni calunniose su certe persone,
e la conseguenza sono stati dei linciaggi.
Poi il post falso viene tolto;
ma intanto, le persone sono morte.
Se veniamo al nostro paese,
e a questi tempi,
c'è una cosa che è oggettiva,
di cui abbiamo una paura
che, però, può trascendere nel paranoico:
la paura dell'attacco terrorista,
in sé fenomeno assolutamente oggettivo.
Tuttavia, anche in Italia -
mentre ci sono stati
attacchi gravi in Francia -
anche in Italia abbiamo molti casi
di persone ansiose
che dicono: “Da quando c'è il terrorismo,
io non esco più di casa”.
Eppure, se guardiamo alle statistiche,
il terrorismo in Italia
non ha ancora fatto vittime -
il terrorismo islamico.
In realtà, ci sono state delle vittime
ma della paura del terrorismo,
quando, a Torino,
una folla è fuggita calpestandosi
per timore di un attacco terrorista
che non c'era stato.
La persona che dice:
“Io non esco di casa
perché fuori potrebbe esserci un killer”
non dice: “Io non esco di casa
perché c'è un killer
che si chiama inquinamento atmosferico”.
Eppure, l'Agenzia Europea dell'Ambiente
ci informa che fa più
di 84.000 morti all'anno in Italia
e quasi mezzo milione, ormai, in Europa.
Un continente pulito.
Vediamo, finalmente, questo diagramma
che rappresenta i principali paesi europei
e, in essi, la presenza
di immigrati musulmani
che sono, ovviamente,
quelli che ci fanno paura
perché fra di loro possono nascondersi
i radicali terroristi.
La linea gialla indica
la loro percentuale reale,
quella grigia indica
quanto le inchieste dicono
che il pubblico crede
sia la presenza dei musulmani.
La linea grigia, vedete,
che è ampiamente superiore al dato reale.
Cioè, c'è un pericolo reale,
ma c'è una paranoia
che è ancora più grossa.
In mezzo a questi dati preoccupanti
vediamo, però, una buona notizia:
la differenza tra dato reale
e dato fantasticato -
la paura immaginaria -
è massima in Ungheria,
dove si ritiene che gli immigrati islamici
siano ben 70 volte
più di quanto sono in realtà.
Cioè tutto è paranoia.
È minima, invece,
in Francia e in Germania -
pur essendo sempre molto alta -
dove abitano milioni e milioni
di immigrati islamici
e lavorano insieme
alla popolazione locale da tempo.
Questo significa, in sostanza,
che la miglior difesa,
contro una degenerazione
di una paura reale in una paura paranoica,
sta nel conoscere chi è diverso,
nel non puntare il dito,
Ma collaborare con lui
e riconoscere che è umano.
Per quello che riguarda
l'inquinamento ambientale, naturalmente,
il dito che dovremmo cercare
di non puntare troppo fuori
dovrebbe rivolgersi qua.
Grazie.
(Applausi)